nous avons besoin de savoir ce qui s'est
passé hier soir nous aimerions vous
poser quelques questions j'ai rien à
cacher je vous écoute le rapport dit que
vous avez tiré plusieurs coups de feu
combien
avertissement vous avez demandé
l'autorisation de tirer le cal
potentiellement armé en approche pas de
certitudes est-ce que j'ai
l'autorisation tirer terminé à quelle
distance était votre cible je voulais
déjà 10 50 m il se pose pas autorisation
tirer terminé à environ 100 mètres
environ plus - à 100 m demande
d'autorisation tirer bordel que
pensez-vous du sergent mulder quand mon
avis petit comté pensez vous qu'il
s'agisse d'un officier compétent mais
c'est vos armes ne tirez pas mulder vous
a donné l'autorisation de tirer ouais on
sait tous que ça s'est pas passé comme
ça qu'est ce que ça peut faire
demande l'autorisation de tirer le
sergent un devoir de répondre tu vois
passer sinon on a un sérieux problème
pourquoi t'as pas répondu je te les
demandé trois fois
vous avez déclaré avoir reçu
l'autorisation de tirer
vous êtes sûr de l'avoir bien compris
évidemment ce sera tout pour le moment